les mauvais traitements étaient
constants fait tant sur le plan
psychologique mais pour l'ensemble de la
fratrie 7 et des brimades notre mère si
on a beaucoup souffert
vous étiez combien pardon initialement
nous étions 4 ensuite se sont greffés
des enfants de la dass
parce qu'on lit oui c'est à dire des
proies
voilà est-ce que ça a été plus loin que
des brimades un mot un peu cet amour un
peu faible que vous que vous utilisez ça
a été plus long que ça n'est ce pas oui
mais des enfants d'être la moins qu'on
voulait pas entrer dans les mines juste
du design et ensuite on va parler des
enfants la dass mais non j'ai pas trop
envie de rentrer dans les détails
non mais je respecte ça tout à fait
alors je rebondis juste deux secondes
ça veut dire que emile louis et votre
moment était famille d'accueil
oui d'ailleurs jacqueline fraysse l'une
des victimes dont on a retrouvé le
squelette et était élevée chez nous
extravagant est ce que comme non c'est
pas extravagant si ce cessez le feu
c'est tout ce qu'on veut c'est madame
est ce que comme dans dans le cadre du
témoignage précédent vous avez été tout
aussi étonné ou un peu moins étonné dans
la mesure où vous avez vous vécu des
violences alors que dans le cas de ces
biens je veux dire du fils mais avec
tous les guillemets qu'il faut de michel
fourniret
comme il était normal a priori il ne
pouvait pas se douter de quoi que ce
soit est ce que vous ça vous a estomaqué
où vous ai dit vous vous êtes dit ça ne
s'est pas étonnant c'est vrai que non
très différent vous doutiez quelque
chose oui depuis très jeune je savais
que c'était pas un être normal et vous
aviez chercher à en parler ou moi je
suis né il ya plus de 60 ans presque
soixante dix même donc parler de ces
choses-là
n'hésitez pas